it's a day that ends in y which means
that president trump
is doing something to irritate the media
which means that in the words of the
apparently immortal journalist carl
bernstein
whatever trump is doing is worse than
watergate
it's not deja vu this is something far
worse than occurred in watergate we have
both a criminal president of the united
states
in donald trump and a subversive
president of the united states
this is the ultimate smoking gun tape it
is the tape with the
evidence of what this president is
willing to do
to undermine the electoral system and
illegally improperly and immorally
try to instigate a coup in any other
presidency
any other presidency this tape would be
evidence
enough to result in the impeachment of
the president of the united states
and really an immediate call by
the members of congress including of his
own party
that he resigned immediately and we need
that call because this of course is
worse
than watergate just like in september
when bob woodward or when
coral bernstein rather said that
president trump downplaying kovid was
worse than watergate or 2019 when he
said that president trump's
phone call with ukraine was worse than
watergate
or in 2017 when bernstein said the
russia probe felt
worse than watergate most things i think
are worse than watergate i'm michael
knowles that's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from jeremy's
rants who said
didn't kamala say she was jewish too
she's literally celebrating every
holiday
pandering yes of course she is and now
she also is apparently stealing lines
from martin luther king
and anecdotes from martin luther king
and pretending that that was her own
childhood
the issue with celebrating every holiday
of course and you see this
from so many liberals who say oh happy
christmas hanukkah kwanzaa solstice
festivus all these sort of things the
problem with celebrating every holiday
is then you are celebrating
no holidays really what you're
celebrating is a kind of liberal
multiculturalism that's the real
religion you're celebrating because if
you're celebrating
christmas then you are not celebrating
the pagan holiday of solstice
if you're celebrating hanukkah you're
not celebrating
kwanzaa you gotta when when you make one
choice about religion when you have one
religious vision
that necessarily excludes the other
visions
but pandering kamala harris doesn't
doesn't want to do that sort of thing
because the real religion on the left is
secular
liberalism not very
uh not very good for our country does
not make us feel
very confident about the future does not
make us feel very secure
in our beliefs very often doesn't make
us feel secure
even in our own data in person which is
why you gotta check out lifelock
it is important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives
you can miss certain identity threats by
just monitoring your credit good thing
there's lifelock lifelock detects a wide
range of identity threats
for instance your social security number
for sale on the dark web
if they detect your information has
potentially been compromised
they will send you an alert very
very important no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses
but lifelock can see threats that you
might miss on your own
i for a very long time thought that
nobody was after my dad i thought oh
that's just for other people no it's
okay
seriously an ounce of prevention is
worth a pound of cure here people
are after your data you can join right
now
and save up to twenty five percent off
your first
year go to lifelock dot com slash
knowles k or w
l e s that is lifelock dot com slash
knowles know w l e s for 25 percent off
you know how fabulous lifelock is we've
been talking about them for a very long
time
go over there protect yourself today
cnn would save a lot of money on
contributor fees
if instead of paying coral bernstein
whatever they've been paying him for 50
years
they or however long cnn's been around i
guess 40 years
they just had a a wind-up doll and it
looked like carl bernstein
and then they pulled the tab and then
when when they let go it said worse than
watergate because that is the only
reason that he is employed by these
networks i'm not
merely making fun of coral bernstein
that is actually the media strategy the
only reason that guy has a job
is so that every six months or a year
they can trot him out on tv and his job
the role that has been scripted for him
is for him to say that whatever
non-traversing of the day is out there
is worse than watergate in this case
because president trump had a phone call
with secretary of state of georgia and
said
hey i want there to be ballot security i
uh look there is
tens of thousands of ballots that look
very fraudulent to me
and we're only down by whatever it is 11
000 or 12 000. so
uh you look into those ballots otherwise
this election could
could be won through fraud on the part
of joe biden
and then they leaked the phone call and
then they take one little two second
clip out of it and then bernstein goes
on and says
worse than watergate the reason i got a
little flubbed up in the introduction
i said woodward accidentally instead of
bernstein because those were the two
journalists
bob woodward and carl bernstein and
bernstein who's the one they trot out
more often
is sort of like the ben affleck to bob
woodward's matt damon
you know bob woodward is the one who has
at least some talent
and coral bernstein just kind of kind of
went along for the ride
beyond all of the nonsensical
allegations of worse than watergate that
we hear from bernstein every six months
think about some of the scandals on the
left
watergate has been blown up into this
massive massive the worst
possible scandal ever it wasn't actually
in the grand scope of presidential
scandals
it wasn't all that big a deal compared
to say
allegations that john kennedy stuffed
the ballot boxes through the daily
machine in illinois in 1960 to steal
that election
perhaps from richard nixon lbj famously
stealing his senate seat in 1948 in
texas that one went all the way up to
the supreme court and the court simply
wouldn't hear the case they didn't even
rule on it
and that is what landed him then in the
vice presidency and then after kennedy's
assassination in the presidency
how about barack obama spying on the
trump campaign in 2016
that seems worse than watergate how
about hillary clinton's campaign
colluding with a foreign adversary
ironically colluding with russia to put
together the bogus steele dossier
to try to subvert the trump campaign
what about that that's certainly worse
than watergate
give me a break i don't want to hear it
anymore i
you know i i don't want to hear anymore
on from the left you'll hear about how
nixon was the most corrupt president
nixon was nothing compared to barack
obama
nixon was no you think nixon was
dishonest that guy's nothing compared to
joe biden who at least would appear to
be about to ascend the presidency
nothing compared to hillary clinton
give me a break they do this also with
mccarthy
you'll always hear about mccarthyism and
this awful mccarthyism
during the during the early 20th century
when this awful senator pretended that
there were communists working
in the federal government there were
communists working in the federal
government we
there was a communist who helped found
the united nations his name was alger
hiss
and he was a very high level employee at
the state department he was at the doj
before that
he was a convicted communist it was i
suppose it was after the statute of
limitations had run it there's a book
about this called witness by whitaker
chambers
it's the book that turned reagan from a
liberal into a conservative for all of
mccarthy's flaws for all of nixon's
flaws they were men
with flaws like everybody else to posit
them as the kind of supreme evil of
political
scandal it's completely ridiculous and
it's a way to distract from the
legitimate democratic scandals
you know we've been hearing a lot over
the past few days
about how ted cruz and josh hawley and
about a dozen senators
along with a hundred to 150 republican
members of congress
are going to object to the certification
of the electoral college results
and what this means is you had the vote
on election day
then huna there was a long process in
some of these states where they just
kept finding votes under a rock
underneath the dresser
and oh lift up the couch cushions they
find some more votes and then
there were some questions about how
these votes were counted transparency
poll watchers
in pennsylvania the violation of the
state constitution pretty
pretty blatant and so then it goes to
the electoral college the electoral
college voted
and then finally the electoral college
votes are read before
the house and the senate and you can
object to this this has happened many
times democrats have done it
much more often than republicans have
even very recently
and so now that republicans want to do
it the the left is throwing a big hissy
fit
some republicans are raising objections
too and i want to take those objections
seriously because i think they merit
consideration even though they're not
very good
liz cheney and tom cotton
are coming out and saying they oppose
the objection to these the certification
because it sets a dangerous precedent
the argument is if republicans are going
to object
to the certification of the electoral
college vote
then democrats might do that to us in
the future
and i would be willing to entertain this
argument
if it were not the case that the
democrats
already do that they've done that
they did it last time they did it a
couple times before that they did it
before that they have done it multiple
times in the
20th century 21st century and famously
we had this issue
in 1876 and which resulted in the
compromise of 1877.
moreover they're going to do it again so
you're telling me i've got to forget
about what the democrats are doing right
now
present tense because it might set
a bad precedent for the future even
though the democrats are already doing
it right now
this reminds me of what what we always
hear from the squishy republicans
on big tech censorship they say we can't
ever
use the government to stop the left from
censoring conservatives right now in the
here and now
because if we do that then they might
use it to censor us in the future
even though they're already censoring us
in the present well then i don't care
about that hypothetical i care about
what's happening right now
i'm not going to give the left an actual
victory right now
so that i can maybe win a hypothetical
victory in the future
after i've already lost right now that
doesn't make any
sense i'm worried about the present
tense
not the precedence can i get an amen to
that
we ask it in the name of the
monotheistic god
brahma and god known by many names
by many different faiths a man
and a woman amen and a woman that is
some
silly uh democratic representative i
don't even remember his name
this democratic representative was
giving this sort of prayerful
invocation and of course he doesn't know
the meaning of the word amen amen does
not have anything to do with being male
or female
it's a very ancient hebrew word and it
has has nothing to do with sex
whatsoever
okay fair enough so we're all laughing
at this guy we're all correcting him
i think that's the wrong strategy i
think that completely misunderstands
what's happening
conservatives are getting this all wrong
in the same way that they get political
correctness
wrong more generally it is not
enough to laugh at these guys while
we're busy
laughing and correcting these guys on
these silly redefinitions and
ridiculous etymologies they're
scoring victories that that's what
remember latinx latinx remember how we
all joked about that
remember how we all joked about turning
chairman into chair
person or chairwoman that was a little i
guess i was in the 90s people joked
about that
then it happened the latinx thing is
being totally mainstreamed
he or her zur being totally mainstreamed
the singular they
being totally mainstreamed what happens
is the left doesn't care about these
etymologies the left doesn't care
they're not going to feel embarrassed if
you say wait actually amen has nothing
to do with men or women
you're going to say yeah whatever now
it's political
now you better say amen or a woman it's
i i have a strong hunch
that this phrase is actually going to be
mainstreamed beyond that listen to the
new standard he says
he invokes the monotheistic god the name
of the monotheistic god brahma
brahma is not the monotheistic god
brahma is the name of a pagan
deity from south asia that is a foreign
deity in the in the united states but
there's the establishment of a new
standard
and this new standard is secular
liberalism and the new standard is
enforced by politically correct speech
codes and politically correct behavior
codes
and we giggle and we correct them and
they enforce the standard there is a way
around this
but conservatives don't quite know how
to do it they can't quite see it and if
you want to see
really well you've got to go to coastal
at coastal.com you can get prescription
glasses starting at
nine dollars with free shipping and 30
day risk-free returns
i didn't say 900 dollars sometimes you
see glasses like no i didn't say 90
dollars i said
nine dollars plus they have the most
advanced virtual try on technology that
you will find
anywhere with coastal you don't have to
spend hours at the store or hundreds of
dollars to get a new style
just go to coastal.com pick the frames
that you want
enter your prescription details and your
glasses will arrive
in just a few days i love it i've never
seen anything like it because this is
the trouble with buying glasses online
you just don't know really how they're
going to look and usually it's just like
a kind of picture
and you put your face there no with
coastal you can see you can turn your
head you can see how they look on the
side it's
really really impressive stuff so
helpful when you want to buy glasses and
you can't beat the prices
for a limited time they are offering our
listeners the best deal they have got
going anywhere
50 off your first pair of glasses at
coastal.com
michael get free shipping 30-day risk
free returns and 50
off at coastal.com michael it's only for
a limited time c-o-a-s-t-a-l
dot com michael some restrictions apply
great way to get very affordable
good looking glasses which you should go
check out immediately
there is a way around this
but it's going to be very difficult for
conservatives the way
that the left is able to trample the
culture and establish these new
standards and get people to start saying
a woman which they're actually going to
do
remember they changed rest in peace to
rest in power rest in power doesn't make
any sense but the left all says it now
so i mean i could the life changed
christmas trees into holiday trees what
holiday are they talking about the only
holiday that has a tree is christmas but
still people now talk about
holiday trees how how do they do it
because the left is willing to defend
their new politically correct standards
they're willing to go out on a limb and
say
you need to use the language that we
want you to use
and the only way conservatives has
responded is hey
we're not going to tell you that you
should say a certain thing or behave in
a certain
way we would never impose on you we
would never force our views on you you
can't legislate those sort of things
but we just just please don't make us do
it
not how it works folks not how speech
codes work not how language works not
how
behavior works either
the christmas tree is going to be you're
going to call it a christmas tree or
you're going to call it a holiday tree
but you're going to call it something
it's going to have a name and the left
is trying to push this view
either we're going to pray to god or
we're going to pray to brahma you're not
going to
pray to both you can't you can't pray to
both actually
and so they so the way political
correctness advances is they destroy the
old standards
they say you're not allowed to say chair
man you're not allowed to pray to god
you're not allowed to say amen you're
not allowed to call it a christmas tree
you're not allowed you're not allowed
you're not allowed you're not allowed
that's offensive that's wrong and
because they believe in their new
standard they're willing to enforce it
we don't really believe in it anymore
the way to actually fight back against
this is to publicly say amen a lot and
really believe it
the way to fight back against this is to
actually have a robust
i suppose you'd say traditional culture
which is heavily heavily christian
culture
and actually believe in it and actually
be willing to make claims about it and
actually say
there is one god his name is god and
that's the god that we worship in the
united states
and we don't worship a bunch of other
gods are you willing to make that claim
are you willing to go out there and
exert those standards are you willing to
say hey
not only is it not the case that men can
become women
but it is disordered that men should
behave like women
and we should discourage them from doing
it are you willing to go that far
are you willing to actually and by the
way when i say that far i mean the thing
everyone would have agreed on 10 years
ago
the idea that men are not women because
the the the rut
that conservatives and the right are
stuck in is they'll say hey
i don't want to make any claims look if
you want if you're a man you want to
pretend to be a woman that's totally
fine it's
i just don't make me do it just don't
well in that case you've established the
principle that a man really can become a
woman
or that it's totally normal or totally
acceptable you've established the
principle that a christmas tree yeah
maybe it's not a christmas tree
you've established the principle that
maybe the god that that
our nation has historically worshipped
that we can find reference to him in the
declaration of independence
and in state constitutions and
in the connecticut code and in the
writings of all of our forefathers
that that maybe that god's actually
brahma right
maybe uh it's not though
and unless we are willing to make
substantive moral claims
which frankly i think most conservatives
are not because i think we're cowardly
and
we think it's impolite or something and
we don't even really believe it much
ourselves
unless we're going to do that you're
going to get amen you're going to you're
not going to get it just amen you're
going to get a woman you're going to get
political correctness this is why
political correctness advances
we laugh at it we joke about it and they
get the wins
new standards you know it was a little
bizarre the other day because i saw that
a
figure on the left this entertainer
james corden he hosts one of the late
shows
james corden is overweight he doesn't
doesn't look super healthy
and he came out and he posted a video
and he said you know i'm going to
partner with weight watchers now
which i think has since renamed
themselves i think they're now called ww
because because these new changing
standards say you're not allowed to
criticize being overweight you're not
allowed to suggest
that it's better to be a healthy weight
than an unhealthy weight so they changed
their name and he says anyway i'm going
to partner with weight watchers because
i feel unhealthy and i want to be
healthier and
i felt it was so refreshing it was so
traditional it was so
sane take a listen i've realized
that every year for the past decade
probably even
15 years on january 1st
i've told myself and anyone that would
listen that this is it this is the year
i'm going on a diet i'm gonna lose a
load of weight
i'm fed up with the way i look i'm fed
up with being unhealthy
and this is it this is the year i'm
doing it and because of that
i've over christmas
eaten everything that's in the fridge
because in my head in january
i'm starting this diet and it'll be a
success and as you can see
well it hasn't um
and it started to get me down in a way
that i've just sort of never really been
able to stick
to anything like that and i think i've
just probably spent a long time just
accepting that this is my body and
and that's it but i really am
sick and tired really of
of just doing the same thing every year
totally understandable totally normal
feeling i think a lot of us have felt it
various times you think i'm just not i'm
not feeling good i should
do something to better myself i'm not
perfect the way that i am none of us is
and we can always do things to maybe
improve our lives and practice some
virtues and
exercise sure okay so he says that
therefore i'm gonna go start
start up with weight watchers but they
won't use that word
weight or that term weight watchers
because there's a new standard
which says no you don't need to be thin
and healthy to be thin and healthy no
actually
these are covers from cosmo magazine
cover says this is healthy and it's an
obviously very
overweight woman who's obviously not
healthy 11 women on why wellness doesn't
have to be
one size fits all now
here here i guess is one of these tricks
posed by
political correctness conservatives want
to be polite if you saw either of these
women on the cover of cosmo
either of these unhealthy women who it
says
this is healthy if you saw either of
them on the street would you walk up to
them and say hey you're
you're unhealthy you're fat you're
unhealthy no nobody would do that that's
impolite we don't want to be impolite
it is the left that is making us say
things that are uncomfortable and might
seem impolite
because they're not merely saying hey be
nice to
people who you know have certain
deficiencies
or people who have certain health
problems or whatever yeah of course no
one needs to tell you that
they're walking up to us and they're
saying hey hey uh 2 plus 2 equals 5
right
2 you need to say that 2 plus 2 equals
5. if you don't say the 2 plus 2 equals
5 you're a bigot and we look at that and
we say look man i don't care
you know if the lady whatever she's got
her own struggles or whatever
but 2 plus 2 does not equal 5. and that
is not healthy
that that is an inversion of standards
it's what political correctness
always does because the whole because it
is a purely
negative movement and i think the amena
women thing is kind of
waking some people up to this it's a
purely
negative movement to overturn everything
we once thought was true to remake the
world
you know john kennedy popularized this
phrase
when he was president and he was
referring to a
socialist playwright george bernard shaw
and he was quoting
shaw and kennedy said some people see
things that are and say
why i dream things that never were and
say
why not and his brother robert kennedy
then used this phrase when he was
running for president then after
robert kennedy died ted kennedy quoted
it at robert's funeral
and a lot of left-wing politicians have
quoted this as an inspiration ever since
then
and one of the funny things about
kennedy quoting literature
is that john kennedy liked to quote
literature but he never read literature
so he's always misquoting all these
authors
dante he's misquoting shaw what he said
what he was quoting from shaw is
actually a scene from a play series
called back to methuselah and that
phrase
comes from the mouth of the serpent in
the garden of eden tempting eve
it is the words of the devil even in
shaw is describing the words of the
devil here
and the left is quoting this is some
great thing but
it reminds me of whitaker chambers who
says communism
you know he's an ex-communist and by by
extension i think we could say all sort
of radical leftism
it is the it's not a new ideology it's
the second oldest
alternative faith of mankind that began
in the art
garden when the serpent said ye shall be
his gods
it's trying to construct a fantasy world
whereby this is healthy
whereby amen is who cares about the
etymology of it who cares about what it
means
it means whatever we say it means and
that nasty word men
is in there and we can't have man in
there because men are bad because
according to the new standard
men are bad and we and the future is
female
and there's actually no such thing as
men or women that
is a a totally new code and if we think
that we're going to oppose that kind of
code
with limp laughing and
with these sort of shallow
encomia to libertinism and you do you
and do whatever you want
we're hoping for something that never
was and never will be no society has
ever existed that way
and ours will not either and it's why we
have continued to lose lose lose
and what do we do to losers we fire them
that's what we do
and we get better people which is why
you need zip recruiter
if you want if you got you know if you
want your team to be performing you got
to hire
really good people best way to find
really good people ziprecruiter when you
post a job on zip recruiter it gets sent
out to over 100 top job sites
with one click then zip recruiters
matching technology scans
thousands of resumes and profiles to
send you the most qualified people for
your job
if you are seriously interested in a
candidate
you can even invite them to apply for
your job with just one click it's not
just like throwing spaghetti at the wall
zip recruiter will go out send an email
from you
and you stand out from the competition
it's so effective that four out of five
employers
who post unzip recruiter get a quality
candidate through the site
within the first day it's the most
important investment that your business
can make is in
people and when you're conducting these
kind of searches time is money you want
to get the best fit right now
you can try ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
knowles that is ziprecruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s
just go to ziprecruiter.com
knowles zip recruiter the absolute 100
smartest way to hire go check them out
also you know
daily wire has been talking for a long
time
we lived in hollywood for a long time
since the beginning of this company
basically we've said
we want to affect culture we want to go
out there we don't want
don't want to just comment on culture
but we actually want to put that culture
out into the world we want to be makers
of culture so that
conservatives can overcome this
criticism we sometimes get
which is that we just whine wine wine
but we never actually go out there and
do
things and produce things well we're
doing that
we the minute we left mussolini's
california we're out here in nashville
we're actually
creating things we have our first movie
coming out it's coming out in 10 days
or less nine days i guess that movie is
run
hide fight make sure you go check out
the run hide fight trailer after the
show
you can check it out on the daily wire
youtube channel and gear up to watch the
premiere
with us in about nine days head on over
to dailywire.com we'll be right back
with a lot more
so you've got the new fat standards
right new standards of weight and beauty
you also have new racial standards and
this one is a little
it's a little more subtle too i i notice
with all these big viral stories going
around
the amen and you know bernstein all
these sorts of things what's more
interesting about them is not what's on
the surface what's more interesting is
what's beneath and this is certainly
true
of a video that went viral it's chenk
yuger he's that
guy from the young turks who just yells
all the time and he's very
vulgar and that's just that's this whole
shtick as he just yells and he's kind of
like
you know the entire left i guess that's
their their shtick they just yell and
say a lot of swear words but
chenkyuger did the thing that everybody
with a blue checkmark on twitter is
tempted to do
at the airport when their flight is
delayed you are
so tempted to just immediately go and
complain on social media i think
we've all done it every single
conservative moderate liberal if you
have
any kind of social media network you
complain about it
and then you you hope that in some
mystical way this will get your plane to
show up
more quickly so chenk loses it because
he's more
excitable than most people the flight's
delayed however many hours
and he starts filming the staff because
he's not getting answers
and he starts starts badgering them take
a listen we've been here three hours
and american airlines sucks
they decided for whatever reason to
screw everybody on this flight
it just frustrates me that some
industries just get to screw you over
and go
yeah you got to fly at some point right
it is gustavo that's a tyt viewer i
and i'm hungry and i'm tired and so
like you know me i i get more agitated
when i'm hungry and tired
so look if you guys think this is bad
wait till if that plane doesn't actually
come from the hangar in 20 minutes
is the flight coming supervisors the
flight coming
supervisor you at least got to be honest
is there a flight
is there a plane you got to be honest is
there a plane
is there a plane where's the plane
where's the plane
okay so it's it's rude he shouldn't do
this
but it's actually kind of funny right
and he's it's not he's not actually red
in the face he's kind of making a joke
about it
and so i'm i actually i can't believe i
have to sort of
defend chenkyuger for being just as rude
as he always is
but not particularly rude what's
interesting in the story to me
is that when this was posted to the
internet sort of went viral
the the comment on it was here is a two
minute video of chenkyuger screaming at
black airline employees because flight
was delayed
why do i care that the airline employees
are black
why do i get why does that make it worse
now i suspect what's happening here
is the the viral post is pointing out
the kind of hypocrisy this irony of the
new
left-wing politically correct standard
which is you know black people are sort
of a special class really any
historically aggrieved minority who can
claim
grievance and victimhood is a special
class entitled to special privileges
and white people are bad in the same way
that you know women are good and any
kind of sexual
sexually confused person is really good
but men are really bad you know and
you see this in the slogans of die white
cis scum you know or
dead white males are terrible and you
got to take them out of university
curricula decolonize the english
department which is very funny because
you know for instance major english
writers just as a sort of by definition
tend to be
white white guys because the english
people are white and so
that you always hear like decolonize get
the white people out of the english
department i think you wouldn't
you wouldn't say get the italians out of
the italian department would you you
wouldn't say get the chinese people out
of the chinese department that's
decolonizing but this is a new standard
it's a new and
obviously identity politics is this it's
creating new
sort of special groups and special
privileges for for various people
but i just think it's it's
counterproductive for conservatives to
do this sort of thing
because i just don't believe it i don't
chooger yelling at a black guy
is in no way worse than him yelling at a
white guy
i it doesn't i don't think it's a
special crime
or some special offense if he does that
uh i do think it's
worse if chanky ugly yells at a woman
than in a man because
there there used to be an old standard
called chivalry and men were supposed to
treat women
differently but i don't think that we
should
treat each other differently on the
basis of our race i think that's a far
more
superficial distinction than sexual
difference which is real
the new standards obliterate all of that
that traditional
understanding of things and i just don't
i think
that it's very easy and actually feels
good
for conservatives to just laugh about
this thing because you can either laugh
or you can cry
but i don't think it's going to help us
fight these new crazy standards
not one little bit i think it's going to
ease the implementation of those
standards because unless we push back
again i mean forget about chunk uger for
a second unless we push back and say no
it's not a women
it's amen that's the word you say and
you say amen
after we have prayer to open up the
congress as we have
for hundreds of years and and you don't
just get to choose whatever word you say
you say the correct word i think there
are going to be a lot of people who are
who have played this game a little more
squishy over the years said look we
don't
we're free speech purists right that's
kind of the traditional conservative
response to
these politically correct standards
we're pure we you can say whatever
you want that isn't true that isn't true
conservatives have always
defended standards i don't think you
should be able to walk up to a woman and
scream obscenities in her face
i think that's wrong and you should be
punished for doing that
i don't think that you should be able to
walk out onto an nfl field and
disrespect the american flag i think
that's an incoherent
act i think to defend it on first
amendment grounds is absurd
because you are you're protesting the
country itself without which you
wouldn't have a first amendment
i don't think you should be able to call
a christmas tree uh some other kind of
name it's not i don't i'm not saying you
should be arrested for it i'm just
saying
we as a society should not tolerate that
sort of thing the left has always
understood this the left is always
understood
that there are always limits to
speech and behavior and conservatives in
fighting against political correctness i
think we just
believed our own abstractions a little
too much but this was true according to
thomas jefferson
this is true according to john locke
this is true according to
john milton the greatest defender of
free speech in the english language
wrote aeropogitica
there are always limits there
necessarily have to be if this leftist
ears tumbler is a tumbler then it's not
a frisbee
and i can't call it a frisbee if i if
i'm really permitted in society to call
this thing a frisbee
then communication totally breaks down
and we have no way of speaking to one
another
and our reasoned self-government
devolves into a bunch of
grunts and violence and
raw passion appetite and self-interest
and increasingly that's the country
we're getting the only way we're going
to be able to push back against that
is if we can actually articulate our own
vision and have the confidence
to defend it it's not just jank with all
these kind of new silly
racial uh standards there's there's
another one
three three acts that were nominated for
the 2021
best children's album grammy award
didn't realize there was a children's
album grammy award
three of them declined their nomination
because they were white
kid you're not alistair mook dog on
fleas and the okie dokie brothers
it's like i'm reading something in the
babylon b these are all musicians i
guess
they said that the lack of of black
nominees
has them turning down their nominations
and mook one of these guys
his his album about called be a pain was
like about martin luther king and
rosa parks and harvey milk who is
an absolute derelict but he's been
turned into sort of a gay civil rights
leader
but he had a very shady life uh
so his whole thing is about this kind of
woke
you know identity politics uh this guy
said that to have a slate of all white
nominees is really tone
deaf uh he'd love to win a grammy but i
don't want it like this where the
playing field's not even what's your
evidence that the playing field's not
even what's the better album what album
do you think is better
that was made by you know some
person of color what what is it
the the mere fact that you're white
doesn't mean you're bad
i mean this is actually this new
standard is why sort of white
identitarian people
were able to get get a little bit of a
foothold
a number of years ago because there was
this campaign that was going up where it
said it's okay to be
white and it was obviously a troll and
people
reacted against it they said how dare
you can't say that it's not okay to be
white
what if you know what if what if people
started tearing down posters that said
it's okay to be
chinese or it's okay to be uh
zambian or it's okay to be french or so
i don't know they probably would tear
dance and that's frankly it's not okay
to be french
but how did we how do we devolve from
sort of tolerance justice you know being
nice to people
that sort of thing two there's a new
rigid caste system and white people
shouldn't win grammys
this actually is also at the heart of
the amen thing
because while conservatives are busy
laughing about how the word
men has nothing to do with the meaning
of the word
amen the problem is not the etymology
it's the it's the premise that men are
bad
right because then if you just see men
in anything you should just take it out
that man is a bad word it's not
the idea that now there are these
certain groups who are bad and we've got
to remove them from society
is a vicious evil unjust idea
and you got to get rid of that it's not
that we got to school people on
the hi the development of language it's
that we've got to take away the silly
premise that men are bad
amen so what's wrong with that first of
all man is a gender-neutral
word it refers to mankind in the
beginning god created man both male and
female he created them
it's king james bible and
so politically correct feminists come in
in the 70s and they say actually we're
women w-i-m-m-i-n
or w-o-m-y-n or whatever kind of
nonsense
and the way that conservatives responded
is they kind of giggled about it and
said oh
how silly how funny the actual response
is no
no you don't get to rewrite every single
word and you don't get to
redefine every single concept and you
don't get to cascade whole swaths of the
society
half the population a little less than
half the population as evil and wrong
you don't get to do that and we're not
going to permit you to do that
so quiet down that this is a big problem
of identity politics and the
the practitioner of identity politics
par excellence today
is the presumptive future vice president
kamala harris
kamala harris doesn't believe a single
thing i don't know that she has one
serious belief in her body she wakes up
in the morning licks her index finger
puts it up in the air
figures out which way the wind is
blowing so harris tells this story to
l magazine a couple months ago
senator harris started her life's work
young she laughs from her gut the way
you would with families she remembers
being wheeled through an oakland
california civil rights march in a
stroller
with no straps with her parents and her
uncle at some point she fell from the
stroller
few safety regulations existed back then
and the adults caught up in the rapture
of protests just kept on marching
by the time they noticed little kamala
was gone and doubled back she was
understandably upset
my mother tells the story about how i'm
fussing harris says
she's like baby what do you want and you
know what kamala said
freedom freedom she even mispronounced
it oh my gosh what a story right
never happened never happened just like
kamala smoking blunts listening to tupac
in college
before tupac's album came out just like
kamala harris celebrating kwanzaa before
kwanzaa even existed
this story also never happened she stole
it from martin luther king
who in an interview to playboy in 1965
said i never will forget a moment in
birmingham when a white policeman
accosted a little negro girl seven or
eight years old
who was walking in a demonstration with
her mother what do you want the
policeman asked her roughly and the
little girl looked him straight in the
eye and answered
freedom she couldn't even pronounce it
but she knew it was beautiful
many times when i've been in sorely
trying situations the memory of that
little little one has come into my mind
and has buoyed me
and that little girl was kamala harris
except it wasn't it wasn't
because kamala harris would have been
one year old at that at that point
and uh as far as we can tell she she
never hung out with martin luther king
she just stole the story she will not
really be called out for this
conservatives will laugh about it we'll
make fun of her
we will uh point out the absurdity of it
and then she will likely become vice
president
and not and the media won't mind won't
be really in part of any of her
biographies she gets a pass
and kamala harris gets a pass because
her entire
political career is trading on
these what should be trivial aspects of
her identity but they're not
because she's practicing identity
politics kamala harris never talks about
her accomplishments
in politics you'll notice she's never
the one who goes out and says
hey you know when i was attorney general
in california man i put so many young
black guys in jail
oh yeah man i locked him up for anything
he even looked at you wrong on the
street i put him in jail
she doesn't talk about that does she
does she
there is some criticism of her actually
for that on identitarian grounds
she doesn't really talk about anything
she's done no laws she's passed
no particular cases she's worked on
because that's that's not what she views
to be her political value she views her
political value
to be the color of her skin and her sex
and that's very pathetic
but it's what she trades on and it's why
she prattles on about made up stories
about kwanzaa and made up stories about
talking about freedom and protests
ripping off martin luther king it's lies
lies lies and
in the meantime we're being told by the
left that we can't listen to
conservative uh officials conservative
politicians
because they're the liars not at the
left it's that
is the lie goes back to methuselah goes
back
to imagining things that never were and
saying why
not now
jake tapper has committed an offense
that i
absolutely cannot tolerate
jake tapper is saying he will not have
kaylee mcinanny on his show anymore
this is terrible i am furious about this
sort of thing
because kaylee mcananie makes all of our
political hearts go pitter-patter the
reason he won't have iran
she lies well there are some people that
are such
um they're just so mendacious i just
wouldn't put them on air
um kaylee mcaney i
never booked her uh jason miller from uh
the trump campaign i would never book
him i mean these are just people who
just
they just tell lies the way that you
know most people breathe
and there was no value in that i don't
view
kellyanne conway the same way she was a
senior advisor to the president
uh she was more of a filibuster and a
subject changer i thought
a subject changer that's right that's
what she would do than uh
than a liar and i think it's different i
really do and there is a there is a
a risk in just like
lumping everybody together there's a big
difference between something like kaylee
mcinney who just like
this is what she does she tells lies all
the time she can't acknowledge reality
so i'm just not i'm just not going to
put somebody like that on air
you think jake tapper is going to put
kamala harris on air
kaylee mcinanny does not lie i don't
think
even you know within the normal
parameters of political figures bending
the truth i don't think she's
particularly
a particularly great offender of that
kamala harris does i mean she
just lies like air so does joe biden
that's why he had to drop out of the
1988 presidential race
all those years ago because he was
already just he just would lie like he
breathes right he would he would go out
he would steal people's speeches
he would make up he made up facts about
his academic
history that was completely bogus do you
think
jake tapper is going to have joe biden
on do you think he's going to have
kamala harrison
something tells me that he will
because it all these standards only
apply to the right and the right needs
to get wise to it and
live up to and push our own standards
and recognize that there are there are
going to be standards in society you got
you got to push them
speaking of discerning truth from
falsehood
we are in the heat of it right now
people are going to be voting in the
georgia senate race
so we'll know the answer to who's going
to control the senate
and we're going to have this vote that
cruz and hawley and other senators are
leading tomorrow on certifying or not
certifying
the the electoral college
and some people are a little more
excitable about this than others
probably the most outlandish claims have
come from the lawyer lynn wood
lynnwood has come out and said
chief justice john roberts and other
powerful individuals
are caught up in a blackmail plot
involving the rape and murder of
children
and this is all being run by the
international intelligence agencies
now the reason why this
even is being brought up at all the
reason why anybody believes in this
is because the intelligence agencies
have lied to us for a very long time
and they have very little credibility my
interest here is not in sussing out
whether or not the chief justice of the
united states as a psychosexual sadist
uh it would see it would seem unlikely
to me
uh if linwood has has evidence then he
should
present it you know i mean that would be
that would be pretty shocking uh that'd
probably give us a lot to talk about for
uh
give us at least a week of shows i think
but what my interest here
is is more how these sort of theories
come about because what the left is
saying is
that the the right is so dishonest and
the right has no care for the truth and
all we do is listen to fake news
that these sort of conspiracy theories
crop up
and that's really all all of our fault
the reason that linwood can go out there
and say that the chief justice of the
united states is a child
rapist and murderer and have any single
person in the country believe him
is because jeffrey epstein
existed i guess he doesn't exist anymore
is because
if if lynwood goes out and says there's
an international cabal
of extremely wealthy influential
pedophiles
and uh and sort of rapists and
all these sorts of things and that
involves heads of industry and heads of
state and even royalty and prime
ministers and presidents
uh the reason he could say that is
because that did happen
i'm not i don't i'm not saying john
roberts is like killing children or
anything but i
i am saying jeffrey epstein existed bill
clinton flew around on his plane a lot
prince andrew had to resign from his
family over this
it's a real that's a real scandal okay
and then jeffrey epstein gets a
sweetheart deal when he finally gets
pinched on this stuff
and the sweetheart deal according to
alex acosta then u.s attorney is because
epstein belonged to intelligence
and because epstein's associate had
direct ties to foreign intelligence
so it's i'm not saying lynnwood is
telling the truth or anything like that
what i'm saying is
the people whose fault it is that there
is no trust in these institutions
or the people running the institutions
it's the fault of
the cia it's the fault of the doj it's
the fault of the fbi
it's the fault of these guys who abused
their power
specifically when it comes to the 2016
election and trying to overthrow trump
it's the fault of bill clinton it's the
fault of prince andrew
people always tie trump to to jeffrey
epstein worth remembering
trump kicked epstein out of his club
right when he
thought he was a shady character so i'm
not saying there was no association but
very different kind of association than
you saw with bill clinton
that's how and then jeffrey epstein
winds up dead in prison
through a series of absolutely
improbable
events and we're just told nope never
mind he killed himself never mind
how on earth was he allowed to kill
himself
the the collapse of faith in the
institutions
is the fault of the left singularly the
fault of the left
and i don't look maybe linwood is a
complete nutter might be
sort of appears that way but it's not
his fault it's not the conservative's
fault
it's the left's fault for doing this and
they do it not even just
through these institutions they do it in
the language itself
when you come when everything's worse
than watergate then i guess watergate
relatively wasn't that bad in the scheme
of political scandals
when the word amen you know i believe
let it so be it that's what when this
word of accord
is now highly politicized into radical
gender politics we lose our ability to
communicate
not our fault we're not the ones who
push that sort of thing the only
way back is for us to
not just throw our hands up in the air
and retreat to the
frivolous shallow slogans that have
gotten us by the last
10 or 15 years on the right we have to
stand for something we need
a moral vision or we will in fact fall
for anything i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadovsky editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021 if you prefer
facts over feelings aren't offended by
the brutal truth and you can still laugh
at the insanity filling our national
news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there